NARRATOR: What's more
thrilling than a shark?
A mob of them.
Sharks might have
invented crowdsourcing.
Every year between May and July,
billions of migrating sardines
come to spawn off the
coast of South Africa,
catering one of the largest
feeding frenzies in the world.
Sharks make the guest list.
Hundreds of copper
sharks swooping through
a dense oily cloud of fish.
[music playing]
The sardines try to
thwart the attack
by banding together into a
tight shimmering disco ball.
When a shark strikes, the
sardines scatter and escape,
or at least that's the plan.
But the battle's not over.
While the sharks harass
the sardines from below,
cape gannets mount
an aerial attack.
Sharks and birds corner
the little fishes,
benefiting them both.
[birds chirping]
Air trapped in their
feathers hampers
the gannets' ability
to dive deep,
so they have to strike hard.
They hit the water head first
with arrow-like posture,
folding their wings
behind them to minimize
the force of impact.
Besieged on all sides, the
sardine defense starts to fail.
[music playing]
To make things worse, a Bryde's
whale crashes the party.
Rising from the depths,
this 15 ton giant devours
sardines by the thousands.
Even the copper sharks give this
50 foot behemoth a wide berth.
And then it's over as
suddenly as it began.